I didn't think I was that disappointed
but this tidal wave of emotion just hit
me
oh my God I'm so sorry
hearing his mom say over and over like
she's too old for sure for you
oh
like you said it like it's not nice you
you acknowledge it's not nice yet you
keep repeating it
hey
yep
I'm calling you right now because
I got really emotional about something
the thing with your mom
she thinks that I'm too old you know and
I'm like
okay
like it's just so hurtful do you get
that how hurtful it is to me and I would
like you to convey that to her and then
if I ever hear her say that ever again
we will never speak again
never never
like what she's like saying over there
because she's like proper housewife
the people
their intentional don't want to help you
look on behalf of her I'm I'm feeling
sorry I don't know if this is a viable
relationship because that's your mom
I'll be definitely in your side but
you're not even willing like I feel like
you should have had this conversation
with them before like please don't point
out the fact that she's older than me
you know could you just be kind
I definitely make them understand that
what
I'm literally very sad about it and I'm
on my knees like I can do for you
anything
you are my other half